attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
papa maman je vous présente ines voilà
c'était pas très chaude pour vous
rencontrer mais comme j'ai beaucoup
insisté la haye la cdtn et des fleurs
cet homme qui les a achetées mais c'est
moi qui vous les offre
ça me permet de faire bonne impression
merci on est vraiment ravis de vous
rencontrer sa dernière copine était
odieuse whittom a le chic pour demander
des poufs en tout cas vous êtes très
belle merci un peu vulgaire mais très
belle et encore tu l'as pas vu en boîte
vous voulez un peu de poulet est non il
est sec et la société liquidée les
pommes de terre selon lui bédié et c'est
normal c'est du surgelé ça m'a pris
trois minutes au micro-ondes
et oui on attendait de voir si on vous
appréciez vraiment avant de se casser le
cul en cuisine
en tout cas ma vente un très beau
chemise et au merci mon chéri ce gentil
sort qu'elle vous grossi un peu mais il
est très joli et d'ailleurs bébé tu fais
juste attention à continuer de sport si
tu vas pas avoir du bide comme ton père
ça c'est sûr qu'à force de bouffer en
cachette entre les repas ça finit
forcément par se voir comme ça vous
allez vivre ensemble obama vous me
connaissez je trop loin et trop vite
donc oui toi t'es pas très bon ça c'est
juste que je me vois mal faire caca
alors qu'il a à côté dans le salon mais
c'est normal d'être pudique au début
vous verrez après vous faire moi même
plus la porte
[Musique]
et bien contre toute attente j'ai été
ravi de vous rencontrer
tu vois je te l'avais dit il sont pas si
relooke son nom moi je suis contente
aussi vous êtes beaucoup moins fun que
votre physique le responsable on est
allé voir mamie à la maison de retraite
elle t'embrasse j'adorais la rencontre
et elle va bien
oh qu'elle est gentil oui elle est en
pleine forme
amen un héritage serait permis à tom
demande en vacances mais à mon avis est
inquiet parce que cet été je sens qu'on
va se faire un beau voyage
[Musique]